my name is Dara Hopwood I'm going to
talk to you about error handling I just
thought I'd include this um slide
because
um Ferguson is only 15 miles away and
the things that are having very
important
okay
um error handling uh we're doing it
wrong
our error handling
fails too often it does the wrong thing
too often
and I want to talk to you about our
handling mechanisms and why they go
wrong and how we can improve them
okay this is just a a summary of The
Talk
um so I'm gonna
um
sort of talk about sequential error
handling first
um and some of the history of that and
patterns and mechanisms that people use
and then I'm going to talk about
rollback Area recovery that's
um sort of rolling back to the previous
state when you get an error and why
that's an improvement on the techniques
that we're using at the moment
um
how to implement rollback Area recovery
efficiently how to integrate it with
other features and then at the end I was
a bit about concurrent error handling
okay
um can you all see the slide the slides
properly yeah good and can you hear me
properly
yeah
okay so
um for our purposes we're going to
Define an error as anything where the
program Strays from what you want it to
do from its usual path and that
definition that that can be in terms of
state or in terms of control flow or
basically anything that goes wrong and
we're keeping that definition vague
because we want to
include we want to make sure that we
don't
um so we include all of the errors that
we want to handle
um so we're going to talk about errors
in programming languages mainly and a
little bit about distributed systems as
well
um obviously operating systems and
Hardware are important and and
error handling techniques are needed for
those as well but um I'm not going to
touch on that
um
so
errors include things that can be
defined either at the language level so
things like divide by zero array index
out of bounds
so that there's no defined semantics for
an operation
or they can be at the program level and
so something
um specific to either your own program
or a library you're using
and they can include
cases
um
either were you've defined something to
be an error case or you've just got the
implementation wrong and your program or
the language itself is not meeting your
specification
and error handling is how we respond to
Iris so we can use mechanisms that are
defined in the language or we can use
just patterns in our code regardless of
whether or not they're using a language
feature or not
um and what we want is dependability we
want
um our programs to do something
reasonable in response to Iris and what
reasonable means is obviously um
dependent on the program where we can
um
we can say that some things definitely
are unreasonable for example accessing
uninitialized memory is always
unreasonable
um
crushing the pro if you want a long
running server crashing that server is
not reasonable
and some of those things can be
um
you find at the language level so if you
use a memory safe language for example
you're going to rule out whole classes
of bugs just by using that language
assuming you don't use unsafe features
but but those tend to be marked
explicitly as unsafe in some languages
if um so providing using those languages
you're going to rule out a lot of
potential bugs so do that first
even before thinking about how you
handle errors within the language
um
so we're going to look at common error
handling mechanisms and what goes wrong
with that
so
we can
um we can have some State some either
Global States and so for a process or
per thread
that tells us what the last error was
and presumably we have some kind of code
that represents there an obvious example
is
erno and C
um
so
the things that can go wrong with this
are because it's Global stage or per
thread State
um
we can our program can our programmers
can misunderstand the conventions for
using it so um I came across this
example when I was researching the talk
and there's an inconsistency between the
posix specification and the secret
specification in how and how is defined
I didn't know this until a few days ago
but if you do what the C standard says
and set no to zero and then call a
function and then call another function
which may succeed and then testoster no
you're doing the wrong thing what you
should have done is tested the return
value from from both of the functions
how many people knew that
two in this audience okay so all of the
rest of you are right who write in C are
writing in correct code presumably
and I would have been writing incorrect
code
um so the path of least resistance is to
not check for a narrow at all so if if
you do nothing the The Lazy thing to do
is to ignore the error
um and if you look at
um real C programs C plus plus programs
um not so much C plus plus because it
has exceptions but of course it it also
has c apis
um this is extremely common that
um programs just don't bother through
error checking
um
and I there's a temptation to just blame
the programmers for that but programmers
are trying to meet deadlines
um people make mistakes
so if we're writing in a language that
has a more expressive error handling
mechanisms we don't we don't need to
blame the programmers
um if
a common pattern is that you're
allocating some resource say or opening
a file
you get an error and then you have to
clean up the resource that you allocated
and then
do the response to the error
and that's an easy thing to get wrong
we'll see some examples of that in the
next slide
but if your language provides mechanisms
and that clean things up automatically
then you're in a better position because
you don't have to write that cleanup
code at all in many cases
um
and just because the error checking is
programmed explicitly you can get it
wrong so um
if you're using a more expressive or
angling mechanism then more of your uh
the error handling is
defined by the language rather than you
having to write it so there's less
opportunity for bugs
okay another very common mechanism is
return codes so your function
returns either some value indicating
success or it returns an error code and
this is
this is probably one of the most common
error handling mechanisms in languages
that don't provide exceptions
um
so
okay what can go wrong here well if
you're having to Define your functions
to return
um either successful in error then
obviously they can't
and your language doesn't support
multiple return values then you can't
return anything else so you're you're
bending your apis out of shape in order
to follow this convention
um
the convention can be different
um between different libraries and
different
programmers and different projects
um
and so if you're used to a certain
convention and you're calling an API
that uses a different convention you're
more likely to get it wrong
if your refactoring code especially if
you're changing it to use a different
convention then
you have to make sure that callers and
the
call functions are consistent and this
actually was one of the causes of some
of the recent security bugs in TLS
libraries
so for example and the certificate
checking bug in canote ALS
there was a certain class of
certificates that would always be
accepted
and the the
reason for this was that there was a
function called check FCA to check if
it's if this is a trusted CA certificate
um
uh so a trust root in other words
um and the convention that was used
um for that function was different from
the convention that was used for the
rest of the library
and then when the code got refactored
someone didn't notice that and they
refactored all the functions in the same
way and they introduced the bug that
caused this kind of certificate to
always be accepted
and actually the cleanup handling was
also a factor here because you had the
code in this function was
um
having to
to jump to a a different place further
down in the code so the
um the error handling code and the the
place where the arrow was happening when
um quite widely separated from each
other so it's more difficult to notice
the problem
um
again we that some of the same problems
as in
um the error status case so the path of
release resistance is still not to check
for the um the error return code
um and if you do need to clean up you
have to remember to return and also want
to propagate the area to the cola you
have to do that correctly
um there was actually a different
um TLS bug in a different Library
um by Apple's version of open SSL
and in that case the cleanup code was
written incorrectly and that actually
bypassed some of the the normal case
code
okay
um so another possible pattern that we
can is used for error handling is to
distinguish
um
some value of a type to indicate an
error so the the obvious example of this
is not a number in the um IEEE 754
floating Point standard
and the SQL null is slightly similar
although it can also be used just for
missing data not for an error as such
and you can also use this as an
object-oriented program pattern you can
define an error
um class or an object so
the problems with this
um well if only some types of our values
so for example double has a float has an
error value called Nan
but Boolean usually doesn't have a
narrow value
so what happens when you compare two
doubles or floats well it if it's if the
input is not a number then
the output has to be either true or
false
and it turns out the decision made by
the standards was false
but that isn't always what you want and
so you can end up hiding errors because
of that or you can end up
well this is a lesser of problem but you
can end up reporting errors where there
were not
um
you can okay so
you could respond to that well every
type should have an error value
but that's just as complicated in in
different ways so when we think about
booleans we're used to them only having
two possible values
um if you at almost the definition of a
Boolean now
there are Logics with more than
um two truth I use but
because they're unfamiliar
um
were more likely to oh
programmers who are unfamiliar with them
are more likely to make mistakes
um and also those Logics tend to satisfy
few are direct rules
um
so when you're so you might rely on an
equivalence that is true for Boolean
logic but not for the logic you're using
um
and that is actually a common problem
for SQL applications
um okay
so
okay how do when we get in our our value
um how do we respond to that how do we
check it you need additional checking
for the error value so you need some
other kind of error handling mechanism
or pattern
to decide what you're going to do in the
case for narrow value
um now sometimes
the definition of the error value can
have that built in so for example in
this floating Point standard IEEE 754
that's the concept of a signaling Nan
um assuming not a number and if you try
to use it then it will cause a floating
Point exception and so that's using some
other error handling mechanism in
conjunction with error values but it's
not clear that in that case using error
values actually gained you very much
um because you might as well have thrown
the exception at the the original source
of the error rather than when you try to
use the signaling error value
um you can there's another way in which
you can end up hiding errors because if
a function is defined not to use a value
then
sometimes it's okay to just ignore that
but sometimes you should have propagated
the error anyway if you don't then you
your application logic is wrong
you can end up storing error values in
places where you didn't want to store
them so
um
if you wanted to to avoid that you'd
have to Define
um different types today for
um a double that can include none or a
double look can't include none
um and most languages weren't
allow you to express that type
if you do store
an error value and then
check it later you've lost the context
of where the error occurred
and
that may be okay but you've also lost
the debugging information
um
so you
in order to record that debugging
information you would have to have
another error handling mechanism
and again it's just as easy to uh emit
tracking for an error as it was in the
era status and return value cases
so as you can tell I don't like error
values
does anyone know what this program is
likely to print
it's a Java program and well I'll tell
you that
none equals double equals none is false
and if you apply referential
transparency then
well these other things are doing the
same thing
um
equals is
just calling the double equals operator
and so it's either but what does this
actually print well it prints false true
false
yeah it's it's not I when I saw this I
was a bit perplexed and then I realized
that we were actually boxing the double
value and when you box it
um it turns into a pointer so this
um in equals itself and equals we're
actually doing pointer comparison and
not double comparison
so because we we've boxed it two
different times then
and the equals one returns false anyway
because they're different pointers but
not for the reason that you would expect
and then this is a consequence of the
fact that not all types have error
values and if your language has implicit
conversions you end up losing an error
value where you didn't intend
okay
so another mechanism so we can we can
have
um a Handler which is set per process or
Perth rad and that points to a function
that we're going to call when we have an
error
um it's a an obvious example of this is
UNIX signals you you install a signal
Handler for some specific signal and it
gets cold when that happens
so
problems with um this is actually the
the earliest use of this I can find is
in pl1
um so it's a very old mechanism
um so
the problem with this is
when your Handler is called you don't
really know the context of the
um the situation that
um that caused the the signal or the
error
um
now for for very coarse grain things
that affect a whole process maybe that's
okay
um but if you want to use it as a
general error handling mechanism for
things that can go wrong in specific
pieces of the code it's way too
cross-grained you would end up setting
handlers far too often and resetting
them and possibly not resetting them by
mistake and and ending up with a
complete mess
okay so that's the first few points
um
you can only have one
um Handler at a time for a given
category of error so
um
if we compare it to something like
exceptions I'm going to assume that you
all understand how exceptions work then
you can have different handlers at
different levels of the stack and if if
one re-raises the error then you can
it will propagate to another one you
can't really do that very easily if the
handlers are set
um per thread of her process
um
so
you also because you don't know the
context in which
um the air originally happened there's
very little that you can safely do in a
Handler
um so you don't know what the the global
state is
um you don't know if you're using a
language that has locks for example you
don't know what locks are held
um you you basically have you can
report there and about the program but
there isn't much else you can do safely
apart from that
um
and in some cases if you consider a
Handler for
um
uh segfold in Unix for example that
that's a case where undefined Behavior
has already happened
um and so you can't guarantee anything
in your Handler
so it's basically an attractive nuisance
that you can even set a Handler for
um
for segmentation faults because it
couldn't possibly be correct it couldn't
possibly do anything independable
okay this is um a much less commonly
used pattern
um which is to but it's used in some
libraries I think it's used in gtk for
example a graphics Library
um and which is to associate a Handler
with an object or some set of objects or
a context that you use to call into the
library
and it has many of the problems that the
um setting a a thread or process Handler
has
it also has additional problems because
you need to make sure that the Handler
is set on all of the things that you
might want to handle errors for
and it's not even clear that
um
the response you want to make so error
actually depends on the object that you
have to set the Handler on
okay and if
if we're calling a Handler that we've
set and somewhere else in the program we
we can't affect the control flow of the
place where the error originally
occurred which is what we often need to
do
so this mechanism isn't really that
expressive and it isn't used very much I
don't think okay exceptions
this is a great Improvement
um so
exceptions were proposed by um John good
enough in
1974-75-ish and there's a paper in
Communications of the ACM I think there
are also a couple of text reports as
well
and there are some other things that
were posed about the same time
um
and this is a really good paper that I
think everyone should read it is a
brilliant case of how to introduce a new
construct into literature because he
didn't just describe exceptions he
described
all of the handling mechanisms that have
gone through just now and explain what
the problems were so my talk is just
almost the reprieves as that paper up to
now
um
well I hope you find it interesting
anyway and uh I hope you read the paper
um
his um definition of exceptions was
quite a bit more General than what we
have in most programming languages that
have exceptions now so things like Java
Ada and whatever
um and all of the languages more recent
than that because it included
um Provisions for changing the control
flow in non-error cases so um it
included things that we would now
probably do with continuations or
generators
I think actually that generators are
probably a better mechanism for and the
things that he was trying to do
um so we'll just can't concentrate on
the error handling subset which is what
actually got adopted into mainstream
languages I think via clue
um
so
okay
so exceptions are a huge Improvement
um the the first
reason is the most important reason in
my opinion is that the default is to
propagate the exception
um so if you're using for example return
codes and you have to in each function
that um calls something that can return
an error
you have to explicitly check for it and
then propagate it to the caller if you
want that to happen
with exceptions that's the default
um
and the because the exception Handler is
only running when you have an error when
you have a catch Clause
um
it can't mess up the
um the non-airocates so if you think
about the
um the the bug in the apples open TLS
open SSL Library
um that was a case where the cleanup
code that was added for error handling
was messing up the the normal control
flow and causing causing an additional
error in that case and that
that can't happen except in catch
classes
um
in some languages you can declare which
are which exceptions
um can happen so for example in Java you
have exceptional declarations
um and I I think that maybe that's not a
popular feature in um Java but or with
Java programmers but that's partly to do
with poor design of Java's
um exception hierarchy rather than any
particular
difficulty with the the feature I mean
basically it's a tape system feature
that's giving you strongly typing for
the set of exceptions that can be thrown
at any given point which by itself is is
perfectly reasonable
Okay so
exceptions are good enough
for most prefaces
and we should use them in preference to
and the things that I was describing
earlier if
if the TLs libraries that I
um mentioned had been using exceptions
then they wouldn't have had these
security bugs that um because everyone
to have to update their servers well
everyone who's using those libraries
um
okay
remaining problems well
um it can be difficult to design a good
categorization for the errors that can
occur
um so ideally we would like to be less
dependent on I'm catching particular
subsets of Errors if we had a language
mechanism that would do something
reasonable
um
for at a wider range of Errors by
default then we wouldn't have to
sort of handle iOS or Arizona database
or whatever categories of error
differently
the the main problem that I want to talk
about in the next third of the talk is
that exceptions don't really solve the
problem of maintaining consistent state
of your program so especially if you're
using an imperative language with mutual
State
um
when you call something and it has an
error you don't know where that error
happened within the implementation of
what you're calling
um and by obstruction you shouldn't need
to care
um but if the thing you're calling was
updating some State you don't know how
much of that state has been updated you
don't know whether the objects that it
was touching and that immutable are
consistent anymore
um and this is um particularly important
for security so
um there's a I've got to I haven't got
it on the slides but there's a concept
called Defensive consistency
which is
um the the object capability security
Community is defined this concept
and it's that
um
an abstraction maintains its consistency
regardless of how its callers use it so
if
um if you have a
some honest callers calling something
and then you have a malicious caller and
is trying to corrupt the state
and then later you have some some more
honest callers
trying to use it
the malicious College shouldn't have
been able to corrupt the state
um
in order to
so that the invariance of the
abstraction no longer hold and it might
do something uh insecure
okay so um this is a um a recognized
problem
um and the uh during the development of
the C plus plus standard
um sort of a sort of pattern of using
exceptions was proposed by um David
Abrahams
um and it basically amounts to a static
effect system so it classifies
operations by
um
of what
can happen when an exception is thrown
so
um there are three levels of guarantees
that implicitly there's also no
guarantee at all and the the operation
might do anything with an exception
occurs but
the three guarantees that are more
useful are first of all the basic
guarantee that the invariance of the
components of preserved that's actually
more a lot more difficult to achieve
than it sounds
um it's pretty strong already even
though this next one is called a strong
guarantee
um so the strong guarantee says
that the operation is basically
transactional with respect to um
exceptions so if an exception is thrown
then the operation hasn't changed any
state at all so um
we because it hasn't changed any state
if we assume that the obstruction was
consistent before then it will be
consistent after
and then there's the no throw guarantee
which says that the operation doesn't
throw exceptions at all
and again it's difficult to say how
realistic that is because
um there may be except exceptions that
are thrown by the language
implementation or if we have a bug in
the code it's very unlikely that we can
say that it um that kind of bug is
reported via an exception
then it's very unlikely that we can say
that it doesn't throw exceptions so so
this is more
um a statement of intent it's a
statement but we intend that an
operation doesn't throw and not that we
can guarantee that it doesn't
um and because this was proposed by
um in the context of C plus plus then
and the the type system of C plus plus
obviously can't guarantee anything like
that we would need a much much stronger
type system to do that probably a
dependent type system
um
okay so
um what's wrong with this apart from the
things that I've already said
well
um for some reason the Unicode
characters have
have done strange things
um oh well that's OpenOffice swing
um
those are just supposed to be areas
okay so if we just consider the no throw
and strong subset
um okay that composes pretty well
um so we can have a no throw routine
calling another no throw routine and
that's completely fine
we can have a strong routine calling no
throw and obviously because the thing
we're calling doesn't throw at all we've
satisfied the
um the constraint that
um but we don't throw all
we don't change state
that's how many strong can can call
strong
um
something a bit more interesting is that
we can call it a strong routine and
catch all of its exceptions and then
um
in the error case and that cat
transaction if we don't throw anything
and then that's valid
that's a valid thing to do in a nursery
routine in other words we can suppress
exceptions
and that's important because if you
consider the just the top three rules
then
um
we wouldn't be able to construct a no
throw routine if we only had strong
things so we would always be getting
weaker all the time
and we can
um we can extend this system a little
bit so
um there's a concept that comes from
the auditing system the E language which
is a little bit like an effect system
but it operates at runtime or it's more
Diamond Dynamic
um and it says that um
we can classify things that transitively
don't point to any neutral state
so if we have a deep Frozen thing
provided we don't pass any Mutual State
into it
then we know that it's we can call it
without and know that it's not going to
mutate anything
so if
okay so if we
call a deep Frozen thing and
um the I've called it with no arguments
here but you can generalize this as well
um
then
we know that because it doesn't have
access to any Mutual State then we can
call up from a strong routine and
that's going to be fine
um
okay what we have here is that we create
some new things that are deep Frozen in
other words
so we can create some new Mutual state
but we know that it isn't aliased it
doesn't Alias anything outside this
block
we can try to call it and this is an
exception we can do something and that
has the strong guarantee and all of that
together has the strong guarantee
um so we can imagine that um we could
build a static effect system and that
would use these rules
um and keep track of
um our exception guarantees for us
um
but is that really enough is that going
to be enough for general purpose
programming
um
well I I think that's actually not the
best way of doing things
um
so
if we add the basic guarantee from
um
the original proposal David Abraham's
proposal it's very difficult to
construct an a stronger or no throw
operation from it so um one thing you
could try to do is copy the thing
catch all exceptions do something strong
and then then that would have the strong
guarantee but notice that we can only
copy here we can only do mutating
operations on the coffee if we want to
do something
that mutates state that is aliased which
is often the reason we want State at all
um then this isn't going to work so we
can't construct something strong from
something basic in that case
um and in the original context where
this was proposed and that for the cease
from C plus plus standard Library
um the these classifiers were were being
applied to the just to the leaf
operations
um defined in the library so that's what
these problems weren't quite so obvious
and these composability problems
um but I I think that for general
purpose programming
um this is going to be too restrictive
and it's not going to be generally
applicable
so
but what would we have to change in
order to make this work well
um if everything had the strong
guarantee
then this would all work work out really
well and we we might still want to keep
track of things that don't throw at all
um but we could very easily compose
some routines that don't throw at all
and everything else that has the strong
guarantee
so I claim that this is what we want we
want to make sure
structurally as a property of the
language
that all of the synchronous code that we
call has this strong exception guarantee
I'm restricting it to synchronous code
um so rather than sort of concurrent
code and I'll explain later why I'm
doing that
okay so this is not a new idea at all
I actually found found this out and the
Thursday before the conference
I was doing research on
of lots of different
error handling mechanisms that have been
proposed and this one is from
1974 five about the same time as
exceptions actually
um
and actually in the original
um proposal for exceptions this was
mentioned as well that when we have an
error
and at the point we handle it we can
potentially roll back all the state
changes to the point where we
um at the start of the the try block as
it would be in a
uh the modernization
okay but this other mechanism called
recovery blocks
that wasn't
um adopted by any subsequent language as
far as I know
um
but
um in recovery blocks
that's an essential part of the
semantics
so a recovery block looks like this we
have an acceptance test which is just
some Boolean condition
and we have a set or a sequence actually
of Alternatives which are just code
blocks
so we
how we execute this is we run the first
code block
and then we check the acceptance test
and if it passes that's fine that's all
we do
if it fails then we roll back the state
to before this alt one block executed
um and then we try out too and then we
run the acceptance test again
if it passes we finish and so on
and then if none of the Alternatives
plus the acceptance test we propagate
the error so and this works a little bit
like exceptions in the in that we can
the default is for errors to propagate
to the column context so it has the
advantages of exceptions
um in that respect
um
but
notice that
um
first of all the the acceptance test is
the same for all of these blocks so
when we're trying to understand this
code
initially we can just look at the
acceptance test
and see that is what this block is
trying to do
um we don't or we shouldn't have to look
at the code for all of the alternatives
and understand all of that code in order
to understand the block and this is
really important because we don't want
to complicate
our programs even further in order to
have them be tolerant to faults
what we would like is
um so so suppose that alt one is some
complicated way of doing something which
is more efficient alt 2 could then be a
simpler implementation of the same thing
that we haven't optimized or it could be
an executable specification for the
thing
um
and then
if alt one fails if it fails in a
detectable way then we fall back to this
executable specification
so we've actually suppressed the error
entirely if we do that you don't have to
use this construct in that way
um it's it's possible just to have a
single
alternative block
um in that case
if
but the way you're structuring it there
is because you have the acceptance test
associated with a particular block
then that's making it clearer that the
acceptance test is what that block is
trying to achieve so it might not seem
useful to have a single block with it
actually is
um
okay the other interesting thing about
this mechanism is that the acceptance
condition can infer to variables both
before and after the lock is executed
um so
you can use that
to Define quite expressive
specifications of what you want to do if
you want to say the state afterwards is
a particular function of the sake before
um then you can express that directly
so I really like this mechanism
um
say
I'm out of time already
okay
um read the rest of the slides can I
have another two or three minutes
okay okay
um
right so
I I'm just gonna
um
explain more of the things I like about
recovery blocks actually and you can
read the the rest of the slides if you
want to and see why I think they're a
good thing to add to
um so to current languages
um
so what your um
it might not be
obvious why this
um
why you should structure the recovery
Block in this particular way
um
but notice that
we have no information
um and intentionally so about the error
that occurred in any of these
Alternatives now that is a loss of
expressiveness to some extent
um and if we wanted to add this to a
modern language we could add back that
expressiveness so we could add we could
Define just exceptions and but with
rollback rather than recovery blocks and
I think that maybe that's a good idea
but for engineering reasons
um I think the construct that we would
want to use in our programs most of the
time is exactly the recovery block
mechanism that was defined in
1975. okay I better stop there then
because I'm out of time